die können jetzt dilaver einsetzen ich
kämpfe nicht mit lava einmal wie
problems macht vorausgesetzt ergreift
uns an wie ok ok einen wunderschönen
guten abend liebe es geht und willkommen
zu einer neuen folge
minecraft pvp heute spielen wir ändern
games die kisten sind unsichtbar
gg ok ich es trotzdem schafft eine zu
erwischen die spiele mit dem technik
gilt das heißt keine großen sprünge
dafür aber große große upgrades wenn wir
einen gegner töten sollten
was doch hoffentlich der fall sein wird
für alle die das techniken nicht kennen
das funktioniert folgendermaßen für
jeden kill wird sämtliches equipment
dass man hat um eine stufe der upgrade
das heißt aus einem holzschwert wird ein
beispiel aus dem häuschen ein logischer
weise aus gar keine rüstung wird leder
rüstung aus der rüstung der golf ressort
ausgeholt reisen rüstung und
schlussendlich wird aus der eisen
rüstung eine die rüstung und das alles
innerhalb von 123 44 kills dadurch sogar
wenn ich mich verrechnet habe eventuell
unter 5 ist natürlich jetzt schwierig
das in villach zu rechnen weil denken in
aufnahme in streams ist schwierig das
finden wir glauben zumindest bei mir ich
bin absolut brain afk und gehirn
abwesend amputiert komplett alles in
allem so wir haben aber nach wie vor
jetzt hier kein material aus dem was man
schwert machen könnten wir würden aber
natürlich ein upgrade regen glaube ich
auf reisen sollten wir in der lage sein
jemanden heute schwer zu klären das
heißt es lohnt sich theoretisch auch mal
hier schwer zu machen
aber nicht so so geht heute wird nicht
holzschwert geht so wo hier die drei
okay
gucken wir mal ob wir mit dem holz mit
jetzt seine chance das ist riskant
ich werde erstmal die geräte nutzen mal
drauf gehen
eventuell haben wir eine chance
okay er hat es geschafft und das holz
wird zum stein schwert natürlich mein
fehler habe ich gar nichts angedacht und
ihr seht ihr jetzt die die rüstung
bekommen
wir benötigten so wusste 118 hatte er
von stein shot er hatte wahrscheinlich
hatte ein standort mit den eisen später
nehmen des eisenstädter das würde mich
zum dia schwert die sache ist aber die
dass die haltbarkeit der sache extrem
verkürzt ist also so ein dia stört was
eigentlich eine haltbarkeit von 1000
hits hat oder so ist nach nach wieviel
jetzt während sein nach 20 hits oder so
schon kaputt also es ist unfassbar
unfassbar verkürzt worden
die halt die haltbarkeit
nichtsdestotrotz noch das geht echt viel
spaß weil man einfach hierdurch ein
paket es egal wie schwierig oder leichte
sind schöne upgrades bekommt so mein
eisenstadt wird jetzt nicht upgrade das
wundert mich ehrlich gesagt moment mal
bin ich wirklich techniker ja ich bin
techniker aber mein schwert nicht knapp
gerettet
vielleicht wird auch bei jedem kino eine
sache der upgrade das kann auch sein
dass sie sagen okay wenn du schon mal
rüstungs upgrade fixed dann kriegst du
nicht auch noch upgrade auf deine waffe
könnte ich mir gut vorstellen immer viel
freiheit wichtig richtig richtig viele
heiltränke da den lava ich weiß nicht
wie könnte die lava immer bei einsätzen
ich kämpfe nicht mit lover ein maler wie
provinz macht vorausgesetzt ergreift uns
an
okay okay alles klar
keine ahnung was der gerade vor hatte in
welchem film herz war es war mir sehr
sehr seltsam aus was war das für ein
kind war es vielleicht 20 der dir immer
schnell sprinten kann sprechen
sprinter renault ich bin heute leider
gezwungen ein bisschen später
aufzunehmen weil max heute eine ganz
ganz große sache irgendwie noch machen
musste davor produziert an diesem
sonntag für die woche was ich ihm
geraten habe zugegebenermaßen also
angesagt magst du musst mal vor
produzieren der macht das ja sonst immer
just in time leisten
und da sagte ich relativ relativ fest
ich werde einfach zwei leute ja
aufnehmen wollen
und das hat mein ratschlag zu erzeugen
hat vorproduziert wunderbar hat dafür
noch ein trailer gemacht heute hat ewig
gedauert aber jetzt ist es kurz vor
sieben und nicht kommen dazu endlich
aufzunehmen und diese ändern games runde
schickt sich an durchaus schön und gut
und angenehm und erfolgreich und
vielversprechend zu verlaufen so du
fragst du mich jetzt mal kurz den hier
und dann mache ich mal den achte mal auf
die haltbarkeit ist ihr schwert okay als
erstes haben sich die fuldaer rüstung
und das ging richtig richtig schnell
selbst gesehen ist eindeutig ist ja viel
sein also leder gold eisen die affiris
ja und zwar angefangen mit gar keine
rüstung wenn man in den luxus kommt mal
mit einer lassen dass man gold rüsten
anzufangen hat man schon nach zwei
kisten voller rüstung und das ist echt
schon ganz schön crazy sodass hier ist
glaube ich schon der letzte gegner muss
ihren anfang macht das mit my day im
plan oder treffen plan wird wir können
jetzt hier so ein bisschen natürlich
deutlich bessere rüstung wir können das
habe ich noch keine nahkampf gehen
wunderbar william buch ist wie er und
man mit dieser technik wird die runde
sehr schön gebockt wer sich gefallen hat
freut würde ich mich sehr bei einem
daumen freude das war glaube ich sehr
kurz und knackig aber weil so ein
bisschen später ist und weil heute viele
ansteht belassen dabei ein hallo ich
habe gerne meine kommentare die ränder
games sehen wollt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder haut rein macht es
gut und schau